wir
hören wir beide seitlich
wir hören auf
vielleicht denken sich jetzt alle von
euch schon hey
[__] sich vielleicht schon ein oder
andere es kam auch extrem viele Gerüchte
tatsächlich rum in den letzten Wochen ob
wir beiden uns zerstritten hätten und
keine Ahnung was weil äh tatsächlich
schon seit einigen Wochen keine Podcast
Folge mehr kam wir können erstmal direkt
den Wind aus dem Segeln nehmen uns
geht's gut ja wir sind nach wie vor
oder sagen der Grund warum keine Podcast
Folgen
ist allerdings dass wir unseren Spotify
Vertrag beendet haben wir haben uns
hingesetzt haben uns Gedanken gemacht
über längeren Zeitraum haben uns gedacht
spotify ist nicht mehr der Partner mit
dem wir eigentlich unser Projekt hier
weiter fortführen wollen wir haben
riesige Pläne
echt riesige Pläne ihr kennt ja unsere
Außendienst folgen und die wollen wir
natürlich weiterhin laufen lassen das
Ganze sehr cool wirken zu lassen und so
wie Wasser wir klappt man das
glaube ich coole Ideen mit dem Podcast
und dafür suchen wir aktuell ein Partner
und nach den Gesprächen mit allen
möglichen Anbietern mit Unternehmen mit
irgendwelchen Dienstleistern die halt
hier die ganzen Kosten decken können
weil das ganze ist teuer auch wenn man
sich denkt auch wenn man nur mich vor
der Kamera sieht aber wir müssen
tatsächlich das Studio bezahlen wir
haben ja die beiden Kameramänner von
Elias die kennt ja die muss man auch
bezahlen dann äh insgesamt sind wir fast
sieben Leute
30.000 40.000 € oder so Kamera Sachen
bezahlen also wir haben einiges an
Kosten mittlerweile wie du schon gesagt
dass sieben Leute arbeiten rund um die
Ohren im Podcast hier das ist echt
ziemlich beschissen
der Grund warum jetzt keine Folgen kam
war einfach weil wir jetzt noch eine
kleine Zwangspause von uns hat ein wir
haben uns nicht zerstritten oder so
entgegen der Spekulation was da vermutet
wurde und rumgeführt wurde uns geht es
sehr gut alles in Ordnung wir sind nur
gerade am schauen wie dieses Projekt
weitergehen kann ob es weitergehen kann
weil wir uns natürlich auch nicht
verändern wollen wir wollen jetzt nicht
uns in irgendeine Schiene reinfügen wie
andere Podcast da z.B vorgehen dass wir
jetzt auf einmal irgendwie so einschlaf
Content machen und uns in den Schlaf
quatschen und dann bessere Sponsoren zu
kriegen oder so wir wollen nicht selber
werden wir wollen weiter unser Ding hier
machen hier in der Wohnung wir wollen
geilen scheiß machen und den besten Fall
für euch das ganze noch zum Vorteil dass
wir wieder auf einen Plattform
vielleicht sogar verfügbar sind ähm
geilere Projekte umsetzen können und so
weiter und so fort darum geht's uns
einfach deswegen kam jetzt keine Folge
deswegen wird vielleicht jetzt auch
erstmal eine kurze Zeit oder längere
Zeit keine Folge kommen wir wissen nicht
ob es morgen weitergeht oder in einer
Woche oder eine Monat so wir sind
wirklich die ganze Zeit im Gesprächen
man muss sagen mit dem ein oder anderen
Partner sind gerade schon so halb auf
einer Zielgeraden also mal schauen
vielleicht kommt in
weiß ich nicht ich kann es nicht
abschätzen
jeden Tag irgendwie mindestens vier
Stunden am telefonieren
gibt's
[Musik]